Speaker 1: Radical and repugnant. Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE is now
claiming that her television turns itself
on to spy on her. No, she's not crazy. No,
she's not taking any medications, as she proudly
has announced, although maybe she should be. As
The Daily Beast reports. GREENE posted a bizarre
thread Sunday morning in which she insinuated
she's being spied on via her television. Yeah, her
first tweet says, Last night in my D.C. residence,
the television turned on by itself and the screen
showed someone's laptop trying to connect to the
TV. Just for the record, I'm very happy. I'm
also very healthy and eat well and exercise a
lot. I don't smoke and never have. I don't take
any medications. I'm not vaccinated. So I'm not
concerned about blood clots, heart conditions,
strokes or anything else. Nor do I have anything
to hide. I just love my country and the people
and know how much they've been screwed over by
the corrupt. People in our government, and I'm
not willing to be quiet about it or willing to
go along with it. Now, it is actually funny
to see how this suppose that we don't care
about our feelings. We only care about our
facts. Crowd immediately accepted this and
said yes. The most likely scenario is indeed that
someone, probably leftists or Antifa are trying
to spy on GREENE through her television.
That's almost certainly what is going on.
Of course, at some point it might be nice to apply
a sort of colloquial version of Occam's Razor. Is
there a simpler explanation here? And of course,
there almost certainly is. Did this not really
happen and is she lying? That's a possibility,
more likely than the one she is outlining. Did she
sit on the remote? That is a possibility. Is it a
smart TV with some kind of learning function that
maybe has figured out a schedule where it believes
Marjorie Taylor GREENE wants to be watching TV?
Sure. Is it her boyfriend, Brian Glenn, the guy
from right side broadcasting who hooked up his
laptop to the TV and it turned on and went
right to the last input that was selected,
like any single one of these explanations would
make more sense. But then but then Marjorie
Taylor GREENE posts an article from CBS News. Your
smart TV might be spying on you. Now, of course,
what that warning means by spying is that without
your consent, it's conceivable that the microphone
function on the TV might be listening to words
or phrases that would then be used to target
advertising towards you, or that a camera could
be gathering data about when you're sitting in
front of the TV versus when. That's that's the
type of spying we're talking about. We're not
talking about leftists remotely turning on
Marjorie's TV in order to be able to listen,
I guess, to whatever the hell it is she's talking
about politically. Okay. So Marjorie Taylor GREENE
insisting she's not on any medications, but maybe
she should be. That would be something to look at.